[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de france 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas tras el repliegue de
las fuerzas ucranianas de la ciudad de
licitadas las tropas rusas reclamaron el
control total de la provincia del lugar
el presidente vladimir putin cantó
victoria en esa zona y ordenó la
continuidad de las ofensivas ahora uno
de los principales objetivos militares
de moscú sería la ciudad de slomianski a
unos 70 kilómetros de distancia la
guerra destruyó las infraestructuras
necesarias y desde entonces la ciudad
lleva un mes sin agua son los bomberos
quienes se encargan entonces de
abastecer a la población y hasta allí
llegaron los reporteros de france 24
en el donbass los bomberos de segovia no
están llevando suministros a una
población es un trabajo que hacen en
toda la ciudad todos los días
estamos repartiendo agua a la gente
ayudando la porque es lo vías que no
tiene agua hace un mes la planta de
bombeo y filtración del globe jan
situada al este quedó cortada en los
combates lo que hizo imposible su
reparación las autoridades de la ciudad
se aseguran de que los bomberos sepan
que se necesita y donde tenemos una
lista con las direcciones
muéstrame la lista por qué
filas como éstas se acumulan cada día
pero tras un mes de escasez la paciencia
se agota
dígale al alcalde que necesitamos dos
camiones para cada edificio no es
suficiente tengo que venir tan lejos
todos los días para conseguir agua
cerraron el gas sellaron todo y bueno
buena suerte en que está pensando este
presidente es el ens que piensa con la
cabeza con los pies porque ha cerrado
todo a mí
[Música]
cómo
el bombardeo empeora
más
[Música]
por a
bueno
fue una bomba de racimo la que creó esta
onda expansiva si una bomba de racimo
después de la cobertura los bomberos
tienen que moverse rápidamente de unos
15 incendios se están produciendo
alrededor de es liviano
acabamos la unidad 1 en camino
[Aplausos]
y
esos también pueden estar en camino y
demasiado rápido tras la caída de él y
sin chance a poco más de 70 kilómetros
al este es lo viernes que ahora se
encuentra directamente en el camino de
los objetivos de vladimir putin para
hacerse con el control total de la
región del tomba si en colombia se
guardara un minuto de silencio por cada
una de las víctimas que dejó el
conflicto armado el país tendría que
permanecer callado durante 17 años es
una de las escalofriantes conclusiones a
las que llegó la comisión de la verdad
un mecanismo creado tras la firma de los
acuerdos de paz entre el gobierno
colombiano y la ahora extinta guerrilla
de las farc que presentó su informe
final a la ciudadanía tras años de
investigación la comisión de la verdad
tuvo que llegar a los territorios más
alejados del país muchos de ellos sin
presencia del estado colombiano con el
objetivo de recoger testimonios tanto de
víctimas como de victimarios veamos el
siguiente informe que nos traen alva
santana y lionel posterior
en este pueblo bañado por el río
magdalena una de cada seis personas ha
sido víctima del conflicto armado como
el exsindicalista ciro quiroz que lleva
toda una vida de lucha cuando era más
joven a peleo por los derechos de los
trabajadores y ahora lo hace por la
memoria esto es un falso positivo
este joven
también víctima recibió amenazas
paramilitares cuando trabajó como líder
sindicalista en una empresa de aceite de
palma a los 90 por él pero sobre todo
por los que murieron exige verdad el
concepto de la verdad
algo sanador algo que brinda una
satisfacción a la vista y como muchos
otros en gamarra tiene esperanzas en las
conclusiones del informe final de la
comisión de la verdad ahora pero como
bbva
bien cómo estás bien como la mesa de
víctimas de gabarró creada a partir de
los acuerdos de paz del 2016 en la
comisión lleva recogiendo testimonios de
víctimas y victimarios
por unos objetivos muy claros brindar
verdad justicia reparación y no
repetición a los colombianos en el
magdalena medio la presencia de
guerrillas como el ln o las farc ep y
sobre todo de grupos paramilitares ha
hecho que el trabajo aquí sea todo un
viaje
por el dolor por la vida por los hombres
y mujeres que abrieron su corazón y su
alma para contárnoslo más arriba en el
cauce fluvial en este pueblo pescador el
río es sinónimo de vida pero también ha
visto mucha sangre luz escapó por poco
de una matanza paramilitar en un
restaurante a ella la violencia le dijo
un trauma
porque por sobre todas las cosas pues
siempre hemos tratado de de echar
adelante cerca del río en
barrancabermeja no todos han dejado
atrás la violencia y alfonso se
autodenomina firmante del acuerdo de paz
pero tiene que llevar un chaleco
antibalas siempre que está en la ciudad
el que una vez fue comandante de las
farc ep es ahora objetivo militar de las
disidencias por luchar por la paz para
nosotros significa algo muy importante
significa una gran unidad de la
implementación del acuerdo de paz porque
como dice la conocida
sin verdad my futuro una de las
consignas que vertebra a la comisión de
la verdad que espera poder dar
respuestas a las víctimas
y ahora vamos hasta parís porque se
conoció la sentencia en el megajuicio
por los atentados del 13 de noviembre de
2015 sala de slam el único miembro
sobreviviente de los comandos islamistas
que perpetraron los ataques fue
declarado culpable y condenado a la
cadena perpetua incondicional un
veredicto que fue recibido con
beneplácito por parte de las familias de
las víctimas de lo que es considerado
hasta hoy como el peor ataque terrorista
en la historia reciente de francia el
siguiente es un reportaje de nuestros
colegas de foster
lágrimas sin mucha emoción ayer en la
salida de la audiencia víctimas
aliviadas tras 10 meses de un proceso
difícil y agotador
hay que aceptar el llorar porque el
dolor está ahí a pesar a pesar del
veredicto y el sufrimiento está ahí no
deja de ser una etapa de
alivio y una impresión un poco como si
uno cierra una puerta y dice ya está
intentar retomar el curso de mi vida
poco a poco porque realmente hay que dar
pasos de descompresión es pero lunes
regreso al trabajo como antes probado el
tribunal condenó a cadena perpetua
irreductible a sala abdeslam con mirada
fulminante e inmóvil dentro del cubículo
no reaccionó al anuncio de la sentencia
para los otros 19 acusados las penas van
de los 2 años de prisión hasta la cadena
perpetua revisable al cabo de 22 años
estamos conmovidos por el discernimiento
y la inteligencia que ha habido es decir
que a los ayudantes a pequeña escala se
les ha tratado como con indulgencia sin
embargo para aquellos que han
participado de forma muy activa en lo
que pasó diría que su pena
suficientemente implacable de clap en
dieta se aplaca habrá tres acusados
comparecían libres condenados a penas
bajas se echaron a llorar tras darse
cuenta que no volverán a la prisión un
momento para la historia a su salida
cuando distintas víctimas los saludan
los reconfortan les dan la mano
les vi llorar esto me ha estado feliz
por ellos de que ellos también puedan
dejar esto atrás reconstruir su vida es
lo que les deseamos
ahora las víctimas podrán pasar página y
perseguir su reconstrucción la mayoría
afirma que no participará en un segundo
proceso si los acusados recurren el
veredicto
hace una década el presidente turco
recep tayip erdogán era conocido por
liderar un gobierno conservador e
islamista pero tolerante cada junio la
ciudad de estambul se llenaba para la
celebración del día del orgullo sin
embargo con el tiempo eso cambió y ahora
la persecución contra este colectivo es
total el gobierno lo tilda de terrorista
de inmoral de podrido y en el siguiente
reporte de adriana rocha y albert naya
comprenderemos las dificultades que
enfrentan los turcos que pertenecen a la
comunidad lgtb
desde hace 7 años el gobierno de turquía
tiene prohibida la marcha del orgullo
sin embargo este año la comunidad lgtb
de pumas intentó llevarla a cabo pero la
policía de estambul atacó e impidió la
celebración de una mujer transexual que
lleva luchando contra esta represión
toda su vida señala que los ataques del
gobierno de recep tayyp erdogán son cada
día más fuertes
primero nos obligan a prostituirse y
después nos llaman los morales pero
quién es el inmoral la iava
quien no se nos da educación ni el
derecho a trabajar ni el derecho a vivir
quién es el inmoral a clark el sistema
no las mujeres transexuales
existen de france
cuando erdogán llegó al poder en 2003 el
gobierno turco mostró una actitud
tolerante con la comunidad sin embargo
en 2015 desde que el presidente salió
con un partido internacionalista la
retórica cambió podridos y terroristas
es la etiqueta que el gobierno turco le
ha dado al colectivo
en turquía cualquiera que vaya en contra
de las políticas o en el discurso
general del gobierno es considerado un
terrorista o un inmoral o alguien
iniciado por un país extranjero
en turquía volvió el miedo a ser parte
de la comunidad lgbt más
en una joven transexual detenida hace
dos meses por la policía sin motivo fue
víctima de violencia en la comisaría aún
recuerda los golpes y las agresiones
tengo miedo cuando salgo a la calle
camino con un spray de pimienta en la
mano si alguien me rosa me asusto
muchísimo miro constantemente a mis
espaldas es muy difícil
tengo 25 años y nadie en mi vida me
había pegado
en el intento de la marcha del orgullo
en estambul la policía detuvo a más de
350 personas pero pese a los insultos la
represión los encarcelamientos y la
violencia la comunidad promete seguir
luchando por su visibilidad
[Música]
muchas gracias por seguir un nuevo
episodio de corresponsales nos damos
cita la próxima semana siga con más
información en france 24 tras 24 punto
com